my name is John Stouffer and I am a
photographer and a father this is our
art time garage part time studio when we
bought the house we knew we needed space
for a studio and really the only access
space in the house that could
potentially have natural light which is
where how we loved to shoot was the
garage and so we busted out the ceiling
we put in three skylights and we just
painted it all white and it's actually
been kind of perfect for us I got into
photography in high school my wife was
taking a black-and-white photography
class and I just thought she was cute so
I did it do our style photography is
timeless virial classic nothing's really
contrived we just capture things the way
they are obviously I think there's a
time and a place for big productions but
a lot of times people relate to things
that are not too overdone I think the
key to a good photo is having a clear
subject and not having your eyes dancing
around the image trying to figure out
what you're looking at personally my
favorite subjects are my family because
their photos that I know that I can go
back in five 10 years and just
completely connect with but I also love
making our day-to-day beautiful and I
think that kind of ties in with the
house to having that as like a beautiful
back